mi primer contacto con la economía
comenzó cuando yo tenía 16 años recuerdo
estar sentado en casa de mis papás me
hicieron una pregunta que es una de las
siete preguntas más estresantes que todo
joven debe de responder según stephen
covey se voltearon y me preguntaron
armando que quieres estudiar la verdad
que hasta ese momento en mi horizonte de
vida quería ser jugador de primera
división y con el real madrid o quería
ser un caballero llegué allí es decir
mis mi horizonte estaba bastante
desproporcionado tiene que comenzar a
verlo de manera real y fue así como con
16 años y en una mesa en el comedor de
mi casa tomé una decisión que me tardé
en total para tomarlas solamente tres
minutos y quiero afectar el resto de mi
vida
en ese momento yo no lo sabía pero
apliqué a un principio el principio
económico de la ventaja absoluta y de la
ventaja comparativa me di cuenta que
mediante un sistema de discriminación
mediante un simple un sistema de
eliminación puede tomar una decisión que
a mis amigos les iba a costar muchísimos
desvelos muchísimas vistas al psicólogo
ya mí solo habían tomado tres minutos
simplemente me di cuenta cuáles eran
aquellas cosas en las que era
comparativamente bueno y desechar
aquellas en las que absolutamente yo era
malo lo cierto es que no me interesaba
la física la química pero me encantaba
la matemática la historia y la filosofía
y llegar a la conclusión de que era muy
probable que economía fuera un buen
match para mí
así que decidí estudiar economía en el
último año de la universidad cuando nos
formamos ya en bloques yo está en el
bloque económico administrativo y conocí
a este personaje
adam smith el padre de la economía
moderna y el fundador del capitalismo lo
primero que nos dijeron cuando entramos
al bachillerato fue que economía no
tenía que ver necesariamente con dinero
esa es una concepción errónea la
economía tenía que ver con la
administración de recursos escasos y la
mejor manera de maximizar beneficios y
adam smith escribe un libro
increíblemente interesante que se llama
la riqueza de las naciones en este libro
el trata de atacar el modelo reinante en
ese momento que era el modelo
mercantilista él decía en su libro que
el mercantilismo definía la riqueza como
tener la mayor cantidad posible de
dinero guardado en una bóveda
el rey no era más rico mientras más
dinero tuviera el rey aunque la gente se
muriera de hambre por las calles todos
hemos visto alguna película de piratas y
sabemos que eran capaces de enterrar sus
fortunas en zonas desiertas en islas
alejadas aunque eso significará que muy
probablemente nunca lo pudieran
recuperar y eso en su intención y en su
cabeza hacía que fueran ricos
adam smith nos decía que esto era
absurdo que si verdaderamente queríamos
generar riqueza teníamos que dejar que
el capital se moviera libremente en la
economía esto tendría un efecto
multiplicador esto va a generar una
espiral ascendente y cada vez vamos a
terminar generando mayor riqueza y al
final eventualmente llegar a un punto de
felicidad
él decía que mientras los mercados
tuvieran mayores posibilidades y
pudieran tomar más decisiones más
felices iban a terminar siendo las
personas de hecho la economía viene de
dos palabras griegas oikos y no mía qué
quiere decir la administración del lugar
lo cual me dice que ya desde los griegos
hay una preocupación sincera por poder
llegar a final de mes pero que también
querían crecer también querían
aprovechar al máximo la cantidad de
siervos que tenían en las casas
querían defenderse o querían expandirse
querían también a ser más productivos
los campos entonces economía tiene que
ver con tomar decisiones que nos ayuden
a tomar y maximizar los beneficios de
acuerdo a lo que estamos de acuerdo a lo
que estamos esperando la economía está
completamente basada en modelos nosotros
como economistas tomamos a la realidad
la disección amos hacemos un espacio muy
pequeño con unas variables
estudiamos qué es lo que pasa cuando se
modifican esas variables
tenemos que hacer supuestos y tenemos
que aplicar un modelo
en economía hay unas palabras mágicas
que se llaman che pedís paribus que
quiere decir todo lo demás permanece
constante y esto daba mucha tranquilidad
cuando tú pones en un modelo 7 dispar y
vos quiere decir que simplemente te
centras en aquellas variables que te
interesan
todo lo demás tendemos a entender que se
va a mantener constante y nada se va a
afectar una vez en un examen en la
universidad hice un modelo fantástico en
la clase de microeconomía y lo apliqué
en el examen cometí el error de no poner
la frase tetris paribus y evidentemente
la puse mal el maestro me llama aparte y
me dijo armando esto no puede pasar te
has equivocado tan feo porque hay una
cantidad increíble de información a la
cual no puedes acceder y no puedes
analizar entonces te olvido' con elche
trees paribus jones y bueno pues yo no
debo olvidar que la ponemos mala yo
recuerdo que en ese momento me estaba
quejando con el pse para que hacemos
modelos que son tan susceptibles de
fallar porque tenemos que hacer modelos
que sabemos que en la vida real es muy
poco probable que sucedan y recuerdo que
su frase me marcó armando si queremos
marcar la realidad
tenemos que identificar los modelos y
los supuestos que está
funcionando en el mercado y los que no
funcionen tenemos que cambiarlo entonces
yo recuerdo que en ese momento a mis 18
años 19 años me di cuenta de la
importancia de los modelos que yo mismo
estaba aplicando en mi vida para tomar
decisiones hasta ese momento me han
permitido entrar becado a una excelente
universidad no morirme de hambre no
tener vicios pero que si yo quería algo
más en mi vida eran modelos bastante
bastante limitados tenía que cambiar mis
supuestos y tenía que poder cambiar el
modelo el modelo del hombre económico
tiene dos supuestos fundamentales el
primero es que todos somos racionales y
esto puede sonar un poquito chistoso
porque sabemos que no siempre somos tan
racionales como deberíamos todos hemos
salido del cine después de ver una
película de llanto y salimos tristes y
salimos a ver sombra 2 aunque sabemos
que lo que pasó en la realidad no nos
afectó en absoluto cuántas veces hemos
visto un partido de fútbol ya perdido
nuestro equipo y hemos dudado enojados
durante horas cuando sabemos que en
realidad no tiene sentido de nuestro
enojo y la irracionalidad económica la
racionalidad económica no
y que verá con un perfecto dominio de
las emociones la racionalidad tiene que
ver con tomar decisiones basadas en un
modelo que me ayuden a maximizar mi
beneficio este modelo de racionalidad me
ayuda muchísimo porque cuando yo entendí
que las personas tomaban decisiones no
porque trataran de afectarme iba a
ayudarme a mí sino porque en su modelo
de toma de decisiones yo era una
variable constante yo formaba parte de
ese 7 dispar y buzz dejé de tomarme las
cosas de forma personal lo cierto es que
yo siempre fui de naturaleza muy enojón
sin embargo en ese momento me di cuenta
que no tenía ningún sentido porque
ninguna decisión estaba destinada o
estaba buscando afectarme ni siquiera
está buscando ayudarme yo no formaba
parte de este sistema de toma de
decisiones y lo cierto es que también me
aplicó en mi vida como inversionista
porque cuando comienzas a invertir en
bolsa de valores y te va bien en una
acción cometes el error de tomarle
cariño compraste una acción cualquiera
digamos eso mismo te comienza a ir bien
y cuando comienza a fallar te cuesta
trabajo venderla porque lo cierto es que
ya te encariñas y tristemente
ganado se termina revirtiendo y vas
perdiendo ganancias aquí hay un punto en
el que no sólo pierdes ganancias sino ya
pierdes lo que habías invertido y es una
pérdida como tal entonces la ventaja del
pensamiento racionalista y del supuesto
racionalista es que nosotros podemos
continuamente ir analizando aquellas
cosas que nos sirvan y que no y aquellas
propiedades personas trabajos
circunstancias que no nos ayuden a
maximizar beneficios con racionalidad
puedo dejarlas de lado al yo comprender
que las otras personas tomaban
decisiones sin intención concreta de
afectarme me fue más sencillo poder
conocerlos más y poder quererlos más lo
cual no quiere decir que yo abrazar a un
masoquismo en ninguna manera estaba yo
dispuesto a aceptar que me hicieran daño
sino simplemente con la misma
racionalidad y con la misma libertad que
me generaba entender cómo funcionaba su
patrón de pensamiento yo también podía
con la misma libertad y con la misma
racionalidad dejarlos ir porque ya no me
estaban maximizando beneficio el segundo
supuesto del hombre económico es que
somos egoístas
el egoísmo tiene una connotación
negativa sin embargo el egoísmo
económico no solamente es bueno sino es
incluso recomendable el egoísmo nosotros
tenemos a entenderlo en general en la
sociedad como la indolencia como la
indiferencia ante las cosas de los demás
cuando en economía tiene que ver con
tomar decisiones toma tomando en
consideración la información que tienes
disponible en este momento para tratar
de maximizar un beneficio tú sabes que
no tienes acceso por completo a toda la
libertad ya toda la variedad de
información que está disponible en el
mercado te volverías locos desarrollaría
es algo que se llama parálisis por
análisis quiere decir cuando tienes
suficiente información que te pones tan
nervioso que no tomas ninguna sino
simplemente con la información con la
que cuentas en este momento te decides
hacer algo y es algo que termina
beneficiando a la sociedad
en mi caso este egoísmo económico
sucedió cuando yo termino mi carrera
tuve un breve espacio en el que trabajé
el ambiente político y la verdad es que
fue una experiencia espantosa para mí me
levantaba en las noches dolor de
estómago insomnio era algo que no estaba
yo disfrutando y no tenía claro que
quería hacer con mi vida cuál es el
siguiente paso entonces decidí dar un
año de mi vida sabático para poderme
dedicar a misiones de ayuda humanitaria
en cuatro estados de la república en el
sureste lo cierto es que disfruté tanto
ese año que ese año se convirtieron en
seis años donde estuve trabajando con
muchos jóvenes y ayudando en diferentes
comunidades algunas de las comunidades
más miserables del país una vez en una
de estas comunidades
sabio practicando con un grupo de
caficultores en chiapas y ellos se
quejaban amargamente de que había un
grupo de empresarios de empresas muy
grandes en el país que les compraban el
café muy por debajo del precio real
esto a ellos les obligaba a vender
aunque no fueran a tener ganancias
simplemente para poder asegurar su
existencia entonces en ese momento tomé
otra decisión egoísta desde el punto de
vista económico con la información que
yo tenía con mis habilidades con mis
recursos y con mi interés me di cuenta
que podía comprarles café por encima de
precio de mercado eliminando
intermediarios y de esta manera generar
una ganancia tanto para ellos como para
mí y así fue como comenzó un proyecto
una cafetería que hace un par de años
fue promovida por las naciones unidas
porque resulta que nosotros sin saberlo
estábamos trabajando con tres objetivos
globales de desarrollo sostenible por
naciones unidas y al final nos fueron
nombrando como empresa ejemplar para que
en otras partes del mundo vieran cómo
era nuestro modelo y terminaban
aplicándolo y lo curioso es que fue una
decisión basada en el egoísmo adam smith
nos decía que el egoísmo era
recomendable tenía un dicho
rezaba no tenemos carne en nuestras
mesas ni fruta en nuestra mesa por la
generosidad del carnicero o del
agricultor tenemos todo esto en nuestro
hogar por su pensamiento egoísta cada
uno de ellos trato de hacer lo que le
convenía y al final nosotros nos
terminamos beneficiando
y este egoísmo es el que ahora mismo nos
decía que cuando tanto productores como
consumidores son egoístas termina
llegando una mano invisible que eleva
todo para que nos lleve a un punto
óptimo una mano invisible que guía a
todos los mercados hasta un punto en el
que haya intercambio
estas estas dos fuerzas economía en la
economía que son oferta y demanda y esta
mano invisible que rige en todos los
mercados funciona por igual en cada uno
de estos en el mercado bursátil en el
mercado de energéticos en el mercado de
productos agrícola y también en el
mercado del amor
lo cierto es tenemos una curva de oferta
pendiente hacia arriba ascendiente y una
pendiente negativa que es la curva de
demanda
lo cierto es que una noche estaba yo
pensando en cómo era la mujer con la que
me quería casar y lo cierto es que en
este diálogo estaba yo platicando con
dios en mis oraciones antes de dormir y
vio un ente de cualidades que lo cierto
es que me terminé enamorando distintas
cualidades no lo conocía físicamente
pero me terminé enamorando
pasados un par de días tuve un
pensamiento que me lo dije qué pasa si
yo estoy esperando una mujer que vale
100 y yo solamente puedo pagar 15 o yo
solamente puedo pagar 20 como voy a
hacer que haya intercambio que ambas
curvas se choquen y al final ella decide
estar conmigo quiero una niña de 100
tengo que ser un hombre de 100 tengo que
esforzarme por ser mejor persona y lo
cierto es que gracias a dios este
pensamiento me libró de muchísimos
problemas y me terminó ayudando en
diciembre pasado gracias a dios
cumplimos 5 años de casados con esta
niña de 100 que me ha obligado
continuamente a ser mejor persona y es
que si tomamos decisiones económicas
podemos asegurar que en el largo plazo
vamos a alcanzar la felicidad
ahora mismo comentaba una fábula donde
decía que para que hubiera intercambio
y un campesino pudiera trabajar en su
propio campo era necesario era
obligatorio que se diera ganancia en
tres grandes rubros a él como productor
tenían que pagarle un salario a el mismo
el mismo campesino como dueño del campo
tenían que pagarle una renta ya él mismo
como obrero tenían que pagarle
beneficios es decir para que tuviera
sentido que este campesino trabajar en
su campo tenía que tener beneficios en
todas las áreas de su vida a veces no
nos damos cuenta pero nosotros somos una
integralidad estamos compuestos por
diferentes aristas por diferentes
aspectos y tenemos que buscar maximizar
cada uno de estos beneficios y si nos
damos cuenta y estamos llegamos a la
conclusión de que las decisiones que
hemos tomado nos han llevado a la
felicidad no te preocupes siempre puedes
tomar nuevas decisiones
cambia tus supuestos revisar el modelo
toma decisiones económicas en el largo
plazo te puedo asegurar que te llevarán
a la felicidad muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]